these are 13 individuals whose families
will be mourning them um
it's a hard number for any given day 13
individuals and not on here is a friend
of mine from northern kentucky that i
just learned about
an hour and a half ago had passed away
after a
multi-month battle with covet 19.
so remember this virus is very very real
and it's still out there so let's make
sure that we light our homes up green
so we ring those bells at 10 a.m and
that we try to reach out
to these families that may be needing
help or other families that while
they might not have had somebody pass
away maybe suffering from food
insecurity
you may be worried about a child in that
household there may be
a domestic violence situation let's make
sure
that we are thinking about what we can
do for others who need our help
at all times during this virus
this is a time that takes more
compassion than
any in my lifetime and that's with every
challenge we face right now
so let's remember that we've got to
listen to each other
we've got to help each other the 13
today
include a 97 year old woman from
jefferson a 69 year old man from warren
a 96 year old woman from fayette an 82
year old male from perry
an 87 year old man from warren an 88
year old man from warren
an 84 year old woman from warren a 62
year old woman from warren
a 97 year old woman from bell a 94 year
old woman from warren
an 89 year old woman from warren an 86
year old woman from christian
and a 90 year old woman from jefferson
county
a couple of the areas and i'm sorry that
brings our total death count to 1137.
and every day that we have a lot of
cases 745 today
we know that they're going to result in
a lot of deaths thankfully
our mortality rate continues to creep
down
but still the higher the volume of the
cases
the more kentuckians we lose so let's
make sure we wear that mask
we socially distance now we cut our
contacts down
we do what it takes a couple of the
areas that we regularly track
long-term care facilities 40 new
residents
37 new staff 14 new deaths attributable
but you know if we look at this now
that's just barely over 50
of of the the total deaths that we've
reported
three new kentucky facilities k through
12 schools a big jump here as you all
know
i think we have close to seven high
school football teams that are under
quarantine
multiple other sports we are seeing
a significant number of cases some that
we wouldn't have known about but for
a different injury 166 new students
59 new faculty or staff 177 new schools
you can get our full report online
remember
it it is behind the news that you would
get and coming up on monday
is when every school has to report to
that dashboard that will go live
on that monday with each school having
to update that
every day so people should be able to
get not in real time but but
every day an update of what the
situation is in their school
and in surrounding schools and in
colleges and universities
33 new students zero new faculty or
staff
eight new colleges or universities
with at least one positive case
before we open it up for questions i
want to mention
the two lmpd officers last night
that were shot they are lmpd major
aubrey gregory he has been
released from the hospital i got a
chance to talk to him uh two last night
uh
personally last night he was surrounded
by family
and friends he's gonna have a full
recovery
uh at least to my knowledge the other is
officer robin
and i think it's uh this roaches
and i apologize to him if i
mispronounced his last name he is stable
and recovering i talked to his mom last
night
during a period where they were still
working to ensure
his stability i want to condemn
this act of violence in the most stark
terms
it is absolutely wrong
and the answer to violence can never be
violence
and we want to make sure that these
individuals that
um were out there last night and will be
out there again tonight
are safe and we need to ensure that any
uh type of of activity or demonstrations
remain non-violent and remain peaceful
we have to understand just one person
can mars something that otherwise
is done the right way and that means we
need to
make sure those around us also do
things the right way
all right with that we'll open it up to
uh to questions
i started over here yesterday i think uh
shelby we'll start with you
president tweeted and said that he spoke
with you can you give us some insights
on your conversation with him
right so last night um after
i learned of the the injuries to
our two law enforcement officers i
returned
to the capitol where i was here for
several hours ensuring that
they were okay that we had the situation
under control talked to the mayor talked
to the chief of police
talked to one of the individuals that
had been shot and then the family
members of the other
also talked to the president of the
united states who initiated
the call his comments were
that it appeared that we had things
under control
he did make an offer if at a later point
we needed additional assistance
he would provide it but but he stated
and and i agree that at this time
we have appropriate levels of law
enforcement or peacekeepers
uh there and that if necessary we have
uh the ability
on the state level uh to increase that
level
of of support it was a good call
i appreciate him making it
for tonight what is the level of
national guard trooper available in
louisville
the question is how are we preparing for
tonight what's the number of national
guard troops in louisville
we're not going to disclose the the
number that's part of the operational
security uh of those individuals
we we will again be
conducting limited missions
that are there for public safety and to
protect critical infrastructure
like our hospitals we will adjust
accordingly to ensure our people are
safe and we can
keep other people safe i want to say
again
that that presence is in no way intended
to stifle people's first amendment
rights to give voice to any anger
frustration but it is there
to both keep people safe and ensure
things like our hospitals can continue
to operate when last night
they were absolutely needed for these
two officers and
and for those that might be suffering
from covet or
or other uh injuries
it's important that those that do want
to give voice
and do want to do that outside in in
louisville
do so before the curfew and i would ask
everyone to respect that curfew
the curfew is being applied to
anyone that is out i know that it was
applied last night to one of the militia
groups
that showed up as well and remember that
those in other groups are
also in the city
and i'm not sure it's them but there are
always individuals that might want to
turn something that is peaceful into
something that's not
that may dislike everybody
including law enforcement and
demonstrators we've got to make sure
that
that that we don't allow that to happen
and that does take a sufficient presence
which will be out the tonight
has recently loosened some restrictions
on visitations for
uh long-term care homes is there any um
discussion about loosening
in-person visitations for us
the question is given that we have
loosened restriction on
visitation for long-term care facilities
is there just
a discussion on loosening it for inmates
there is discussion
uh it hasn't moved beyond any of those
stages yet
so we don't have any step to announce um
nor should it suggest that we're going
to have a step to announce but there it
is being discussed
understanding that people uh very much
especially in that situation
rely on on those personal interactions
tom governor given again
the indictment yesterday um does this
give you any more impetus to equip
the ksp with body cameras
the question is given the indictments
yesterday
um is it any more impetus for for ksp
and
and body cameras i mean that's a a
question we absolutely
uh have to address uh as we see more and
more law enforcement out there wearing
them
we've got to talk
with the kentucky state police about it
i believe that body cameras can protect
an officer or
in this case it would be a trooper
as much as as as anything else i can
tell you aside from
some of these tragic situations where
body camera footage is needed just to
know what happened in many instances
there can be complaints against an
officer or trooper that if you have the
body camera footage
you can dismiss them pretty quickly
remember these sometimes are heated
exchanges and sometimes having the video
with that
officer being professional
which is almost always the case can be
very helpful the other thing that it can
be
is a a tool whereby supervisors can
ensure that that people are following
the training
that they've had i remember being in
washington dc for a
national attorney general's association
meeting and the then
chief of the d.c police she talked about
how she would take that footage home
and watch it and see that there were
instances she talked about one
domestic violence situation where one of
the officers turned their back now
that wasn't that wasn't anything between
um
the individuals but could have
compromised their safety and so it was
a check on on different ways that she
thought that she could use to improve
the department um i am for body cameras
where appropriate there are some
instances where i don't think that they
would be based on the particular mission
of of that individual unit i want to ask
about some comments he made on msnbc
earlier today in regards to your request
for the attorney general to
publish more information about the
briana taylor investigation online
you said the release of that of those
details
wouldn't impact the federal civil rights
investigation
how is that possible to not impact that
investigation by making some of those
details public
uh so today the question is on on
on one of the cable news shows i talked
about how i believe that
the attorney general can release the
information from his criminal
investigation
without impacting the the federal civil
rights
investigation i believe that there are
very different investigations that are
prove
that that set out to to determine uh
very different uh
things i don't think a ballistics report
for instance is going to have
an impact on a civil rights
investigation and if they believe that
it does i think that
that the federal prosecutors can come
forward and explain
um the the specifics of that but at this
point with the attorney general saying
he is not pursuing
certain things um then then i believe it
makes it appropriate to provide the
facts the information the evidence and
it's it's about trusting the people of
kentucky
i trust that if they have all the facts
the evidence and maybe some explanation
if needed that they can process it
and i know the attorney general talks
about the truth and i talk about the
truth i think we ought to let the people
of kentucky
now see all of that evaluate and and
come to the truth
um i believe that it is fully
appropriate to do at this point in time
i've been a prosecutor i withheld uh
judgment on that until we've we've
reached the stage but at this point
put it all online put everything that
that would not impact now there has been
one indictment
um with with three charges in it put
everything online that wouldn't impact
that and
and that's really about apparently
shooting into a a different apartment
building
and let people see it and it's been done
in other places it was done several
months later in ferguson it's been done
by
uh other prosecutors it's it's an
attempt to be transparent
and i've i've seen firsthand that when
you are willing to be transparent with
the people of kentucky
they will look at the information they
will try to understand the decisions
you've made they may disagree
but at least it's not a vacuum uh where
where
different emotions or theories or others
can can come into play
i'm sorry we where'd you wait is it john
okay welcome
um i had a question for you about
coronavirus cases are higher now
than earlier in the pandemic when we had
more severe restrictions
um but over the past two months those
restrictions have been rolled back a
little bit
so i'm just curious to know you know
what what would it take for you to
implement
new restrictions uh for the things like
public gatherings and things that you
had or
earlier so the question is with us now
being at a higher level of total cases
than we were earlier but but but
obviously we've gotten better at
treating when we look at it we've also
follow our hospital data
and right now i would say we are at a
place where we can handle
more cases than previously we're also
testing more to find more people who
haven't that's a good thing but but you
are right
in that with loosening restrictions it
means people have more contacts and we
will see the virus spread more
what it would take for me to implement
new restrictions
would be what we saw when we had to cut
restaurants for a period of time
and bars and that is a proof of or
indications of a real escalation
and not something that might be you know
kind of up and down or remember our
plateaus aren't entirely flat
and not something just very gradual
where it'll take a couple weeks to see
but if we started seeing what looked
like an escalation especially one
that looks like it could turn into a
severe escalation like we saw in florida
and arizona
once you start seeing that curve that's
when we would take additional action
that's when the white house would ask us
to take additional action
uh and and they they're keeping track
like we are we use somewhat different
data but we're in about the same place
right now
in that um mainly what we need people to
do
is be a little bit better uh more people
wearing the mask in the white house
again says we not only should have a
mass mandate but i should be encouraging
it every day
um engaging in that social distancing
and remember
moderation and not moderation like we
had before march
but moderation in on the same day if
you're going to work and going to the
gym
and and going to dinner that's just too
many contacts we got to we got to spread
them out
and and make sure that those gatherings
which we still have that 10 person limit
we keep at that level we do see a lot of
spread in those
it's not necessarily backyard barbecue
but it's house parties and as it gets
colder and people drive inside that's
going to be more important than than
ever
show me when are so many parents are at
home helping their children with
virtual school but history is unfolding
outside
how can they explain what is happening
to their children
the question is with so many kids at
home but history
going on outside how do they explain
what's happening
to their children first it's going to be
a little late
because i was dealing with 6th grade
geometry
with my son will be in governor doesn't
stop
your obligations no your duty uh as a
parent
um and uh boy we uh
we certainly appreciate our teachers uh
when we're asked to step
up and and take a a bigger uh role
i i think that parents need to be able
to have
age appropriate conversations with their
with their children
and that they ought to be based uh in
values
about the type of world that we think we
should have about
true dignity for all people about the
fact that uh
i believe that god calls on us to build
a world that
that is free of inequities and
oppression and
and racism and then need to be able to
talk to their
kids about our country's history
and and the fact that we have had to
make changes and take strides at many
points in our history and right now that
we're being called on
to do more uh you know it's a
it's a it's a conversation with with
what's going on there and also with
what's going on in in covet 19 that's
going to shape
so much but i'd like to think that every
challenge gives us an opportunity to
build a better day
and maybe to raise better people
part of that calls on us to recognize
what we're living through both the
pandemic and
um calls for a more equitable society
and then to to make sure we're
instilling the right values in our kids
and i i just remind people because
i have to remind myself that our kids
are always listening
and my kids are always hiding behind the
door listening to
everything and so well we got to really
make sure in our heart and our in our
mind we're not just saying the right
things but we believe them
and we start feeling ways that we think
wait a minute
i shouldn't i mean that's a time that
we're called on to be a little better
uh and so much of what we see because we
are inside is on
facebook and twitter which i mean it's
turned into poison
um in so many ways uh let's remember
that if
we're writing something down that
contains hate or
or anger or making enemies out of one
another
our kids are going to read that one day
too and maybe if we write it we ought to
look at it
we ought to realize that we need to
change too
and be a little better and maybe we just
need to turn it off
entirely all right what do i think about
including or not including university
cases and considering community spread
um you know i believe a university is a
part of a community those kids go to
restaurants they they go to bars they go
to different places
in the community now there is a
challenge here
and it's one that we've got to discuss
and it especially impacts where i went
to school fayette county public schools
right now uk has so many cases that it
may push fayette county red
and if uk stays open and continues to
have those amount of cases
it could potentially keep it red and
then you've got fayette county public
schools that's saying wait
you know we need a we need a community
spread that is low enough to where our
kids can go to school that is a
real issue i talked to the
superintendent about it the other day
um and and we're continuing to to have
discussions i talked to
uh mayor gordon about it uh as well
and and we the answer can't be
the university cases just don't count
because they are
in the community the question is how we
can
make sure we're taking the right steps
so k through 12 students
don't miss out on on on opportunities
because of other decisions
but this also makes us
rise up elevate our thinking
that that it's more than just the
institution or institutions we serve
it's the communities around us that can
be uh impacted
supreme court's ruling that historical
force racing uh gambling devices are
essentially no different
slot machine is illegal uh the supreme
court today
uh ruled that certain types of instant
racing
games are not paramutual and therefore
i believe that they believe that they
were unlawful
uh i will tell you that i believe that
that uh
decision while well not criticizing the
legal aspects of it not having analyzed
it
is is devastating for so many kentucky
jobs
for the horse industry
and for the the budget in the state
budget which it adds about 21 million
dollars to
uh every year and and that's growing
so i've already begun discussions with
various partners about finding a path
forward we've now had this in the
commonwealth for
several years we have not seen the ills
that people claim
would come from it coming from it there
is
widespread gaming much more than this
over just about
every single one of our borders right
now
if it's going to take a legislative
change we need to make the legislative
change
to keep our horse industry competitive
but to keep our commonwealth competitive
listen we need a lot more types of
gaming to compete with those around us
i mean indiana using our money to build
their roads and
and other states around us missouri they
can pay for their
health care costs uh and and in this
period of covet 19
uh revenue from those sources for the
most part hasn't gone down
or not nearly as much once things uh
reopened and so
we're going to find ourselves at not
being competitive
and what is otherwise a free market
that's out there
and so i hope that uh that that we will
get the necessary changes
uh to to move forward and when we make
them i hope that
maybe we can maybe we can make a a lot
more
jesse jackson just called for athletes
to boycott
the university of kentucky and the
university of louisville
and other economic boycotts and mobile
over the
train jury not deciding anyone
do you want to respond to that i'm told
that jesse jackson has
asked athletes to
boycott uk uofl or
because of the grand jury decision i i
respect
reverend jackson but they didn't have
any control
uh uk or uofl over over what those grand
juries
what the grand jury did i believe that
they
are are trying through programs and and
efforts to build
uh a better world and and so while i i
very much respect
reverend jackson i i don't agree uh with
a boycott of
of of those that have had no control
over this uh now
what i do think we ought to do is see
all the information
i think the attorney general can post it
uh online
if he if there are some that that needs
to be held back because of the
the the one indictment then you know
that that's a discussion and an
explanation he can provide but it's time
to give the information
and i think that if he did um this call
for a boycott wouldn't have happened yet
because i think everybody be sitting
down
and would be trying to process the true
facts and
and and evidence that's out there and i
think everybody benefits from the truth
governor governor holcomb in indiana
has issued a order that beginning
saturday all restaurants and bars can
fully
open in indiana um
you have anything that's you know in the
works for our
cars and restaurants here in kentucky so
i haven't seen it's it's apparently an
order from hulk uh further opening bars
and restaurants that's something i'll
have to talk to
him about uh with us just about to start
opening schools we've got to get that
done
first before we consider uh any other
capacities let's see this is wanting a
response
to this
quote about a.g releasing more info we
appreciate governor beshear's team
providing assistance to our office and
the commonwealth
over the last few days in preparation
for yesterday's announcement
however releasing that information would
compromise the federal investigation and
violate a prosecutor
prosecutor's ethical duties so we did
work well with the attorney general's
office
in in communication uh leading up to it
uh i don't have an argument there
um i've tried not to to to to criticize
um the other parts having not seen
the file but i've been a prosecutor
and have been in that role and if you
are no longer pursuing those
charges there is not a duty uh there is
not a jury
that you could compromise there is no um
criminal investigation can compromise
and so i do not think there can be a
violation
of those duties i'm not the only one uh
in my office i have the former
uh deputy attorney general and a former
district judge
and and he agrees uh too i just
i i don't agree with with that view
other prosecutors have done it let's
just
put it out there and and and let people
see it
do you feel like the 9 o'clock curfew is
actually effective
at minimizing the tension
in louisville in regards to the protests
that are happening out there
question is on the 9 a.m at 9 00 pm uh
9 p.m curfew in louisville i think it's
necessary
i know a lot of people um may not like
it but as we see the nights
go further along there is just um more
of an opportunity for for those that
would want to incite violence uh or take
advantage of
uh an opportunity uh uh
and and and i believe that it's it's
necessary but remember
it applies to everybody and so for
instance these
these groups that claim that they are
keeping the peace that are heavily
armored walking around
uh louisville with what i understand is
no tactical training at all
and no specific mission it makes them go
home too
and uh from somebody that has dealt with
them firsthand i think them going home
is a really good idea
i just don't think that they ought to
show up in louisville in the first place
you mentioned schools just knowing i
wanted to ask um are we still on track
to have the successful real thing that
you're envisioning and are there any
trends
that could put that at risk that you
guys are spotted uh can we if we do have
the incident map for today
james if we don't that's okay every day
we update our
incident uh rate map on kykovic19.ky.gov
what that shows is we have many counties
that are in the yellow or the green
that are we think in a good position to
start some in-person class activities
we have others in the orange that need
to be careful and and small groups would
be
best a hybrid model after after that
and then we have those in the red that i
do not think should be starting in
person class and if they are in in
person class
they are moved to virtual until they can
move uh out of the
the red um i believe that in many places
there can be a successful reopening but
what a successful reopening
is in covid it doesn't look like what it
did before
um it's our our kids and masks all day
long because that's gonna be
required to to lessen the spread
it's going to be fewer kids in a
classroom it may be
them not being there as many hours of
the day but it is more direct
interaction with their teachers which we
know
is important but the other thing is we
got to be fluid and we got to be
flexible
we have seen as we've been here that
there are counties that will have very
few cases and then boom
you know 60 90 100 in
in just a couple days or or over a week
and so we've got to understand that you
could even be in the green or in the
yellow
and by this time next week you could be
in the red and you got to be prepared
to move from that in person back to nti
and then come back again
you know the two things we've got to
continue to defeat this virus
is to be strong to have the endurance to
do this as long as it takes
but number two to be flexible and
knowing the conditions on the ground
in your county and your area can change
really quickly and so we've got to be
able to change
our approach i'll do one more set if you
all
have them let's see did i respond to the
president's offer
for federal assistance to respond to the
protests uh the president i agreed
that right now we had sufficient assets
and that and that
didn't need um that help
and and again um it was a positive
conversation
uh about what was already in place
last week nursing homes were given
federal guidelines saying they could
resume
indoor visits and now if they're in a
red zone that counties in a red zone
how does that affect them who do they
follow the state or
so on on nursing home visits the the
uh or long-term care facilities they
have to follow the state
guidelines that have been put out there
we think that they are very reasonable
following the incident rate map
as well and and i think it it also
allows our communities to know
how safe or unsafe it could be you know
just because someone tells you you can
do something
sometimes you shouldn't do something and